ladies and gentlemen welcome to the FIR
axis mega panel at PAX south
like to thank you all so much for coming
here to kick off the FREX mega panel I'm
your host Chris waters normally I'm
found on gamespot com a website where
we're spend our days being as passionate
as you are about video games only with
video team and programmers and a website
to share it with all of you I'm going to
be moderating the discussion today as we
talk about Sid Meier's starships and
civilization beyond Earth and get to see
the game in action towards the end of
the panel very very exciting it's the
game that had to play really coy with in
the description of the panel but you
didn't have to play coy with the names
of these gentlemen here they're the ones
you're here to see talk so without
further ado I'm going to pass it here to
let them introduce themselves to all of
you hello
thanks for coming I'm Sid Meier I'm will
Miller
and I'm David McKenna all right well you
all clearly know the name of Sid Meier
and Sid Meier starships just announced
earlier this week is that the new game
we're gonna be talking about and seeing
in action will Miller and David
McDonough work Oh leave designers on
civilization beyond Earth let me get a
big round of applause for NU playback
now I don't know about many of you but
when I first heard about starships ah of
course the question comes up well so is
this like DLC food beyond Earth is it
before beyond Earth like what's the
connection because obviously it make one
spacefaring game and then you make
another one they're not going to be
totally independent of each other so
guys let's start off by talking about
the connections sort of where does
starships fall in relation to be on
earth well starships actually kind of
looking back I've realized that all the
games that I've done have been based on
things that kind of intrigued me or
excited me when I was a kid whether it's
pirates or railroads or civil war stuff
like that and we kind of triggered this
whole process in my mind was when I was
12 years old the original Star Trek
series came out on television I remember
every Friday night rushing home to watch
Star Trek and the wild wild west and I
think as a young teenager that left an
impression on me but since then I really
haven't had a chance to to write a
science-fiction game when I saw what
well and Dave were doing with with
beyond Earth they had really created
this awesome story this really
compelling story as mankind leaves earth
and settles in a new planet and
struggles to kind of establish
themselves there and it really seemed
like there was an opportunity for me to
kind of take this fascination with
science fiction that i had developed as
a kid
and kind of tell the next chapter in
that story and really starships is about
what happens when we leave that planet
and part of the the story that will and
Dave develop is this idea of the seating
that people from Earth have gone to many
different places and so the question is
what's happened to all these people as
they went to these different planets and
that's one of the things that that
starships kind of starts to explore and
is part of the the the fantasy of
starships but I think it really is was
kind of inspired but by the by the story
that will and Dave were able to put
together for beyond Earth making a
science-fiction game is a lot about what
you what you choose not to put in it
it's such a wide space to work in so it
was a great opportunity for us when
making beyond Earth to tell the story of
a single planet and mankind's journey
from small civilization there to a
thriving empire but we left a lot on the
table I think when we're telling the
story of galactic survival galactic
conquest and that's where starships
picks up it's important to note that
starships exists in the same fictional
universe is beyond Earth but it's not
it's not beyond Earth to you know
there's still a lot of beyond our story
left to tell this is a new thing you
don't have to have beyond Earth to play
it you don't have to have starships to
play beyond Earth there's some
connections between the two which we're
going to let you figure out but they
exist in this larger fictional universe
which has been really fun to design in
well we're going to talk about some of
those connections in just a few minutes
but first I want to take a quick detour
to talk about the different teams at
Firaxis because while you guys are
working on civ beyond Earth and you have
an X com team maybe you've got you know
the studios are no stranger to segmented
teams but Sid the crew you've got
together to make starships is a little
bit different yeah I've been working
with this team for a while and we kind
of have been given a little bit of
flexibility and freedom to choose
different topics and that's really kind
of how starships got got done it's not
really a sequel or based on an existing
franchise so with our team we're kind of
allowed every now and then to
a topic we want to tackle and and and
and do it but I want to assure everyone
that we did not steal a team from
another project and whatever game you
want us to make we're probably making it
right now so don't worry about that's
exciting ah all right well let's get
back to the connections between beyond
Earth and starships let's let's get into
it a little bit because i think you know
from the art people have seen they
clearly share that kind of visual style
but what other kind of sort of broader
thematic connections are there between
the two games well I think as will
mentioned part of the challenge of
making a sci-fi game is what not to put
in there because there's so many things
you could add there's just such a rich
world I think the other challenge is
with a historical game with many of the
games we've done you're the player is
already familiar with the world that
they're entering into a civilization you
understand and you know the Gunpowder is
probably gonna be handy somewhere down
the road or electricity the wheel these
are all these are all concepts that you
run into and you understand but in a
science-fiction game there's less
familiarity with with the world you
might think however there is such a rich
set of conventions i think in sci-fi
that we always are dealing with the same
situation where you you understand
pineal lasers are going to be handy for
things you what what what what cloaking
is which shields are you know there's
some concepts that I think are our
common currency in the in the world of
sighs by and again with with games that
we try to make we want you to step into
a world that you're already comfortable
with and tell your own story in that
world so that was part of the challenge
I think in terms of making these games
and part of the connection is to create
a story that resonated but felt somewhat
familiar so you'd feel comfortable
playing the game yeah one of the things
we we've said a lot when we've been
talking about beyond Earth is how we
really try to design the game from a
position of plausibility where the
technologies and the things that you do
when you first land on Planet are pretty
recognizable and they look like stuff
that we might actually figure out how to
do in 60 years or so and you play
forward from that into much more
fantastic four to go
sci fi space and since game picks up
even further in the future when that
what seemed elaborate at the end of the
under it will now seem mundane and
you're you're doing the same things but
on a much more much grander galactic
scale so a lot of the lot of the terms a
lot of the artistry a lot of the visuals
in starship sort of link directly back
to the stuff that you are exploring and
developing for yourself and beyond Earth
which is part of why we we have such a
fun time playing his game and why we
enjoyed seeing and get developed it's
like the idea is that we were developing
like like the affinities and the way
that the leaders change over time and
sort of the philosophical perspectives
on how you should approach the problems
of the planet and human civilization he
picked up with and ran even further into
the future its own take on the the ideas
that had their seeds in the under it's
really a really very gratifying for two
halves admire find our stuff compelling
enough to make a game that spins it off
so are we you know the affinity stuff
right yeah your leader you say you go
full supremacy they start looking pretty
not human or they've got stuff bolted on
you know around their face you can still
recognize them I talked about the
affinity you know not just in sort of
the visual style but in I guess how is
how do affinities come to come to bear
in starships as sort of a tactical
consideration I think one of the things
that we love to do with our games is to
make sure they have a lot of
replayability that even though if you
play the game once there are many many
different ways to play and the
affinities are actually one of the tools
we use to do that that the affinity that
you choose at the beginning of starships
kind of gives you a certain set of
advantages that might lead you down a
certain path whereas with another game
you might choose a different affinity
and that would kind of take you in a
different direction a little bit like
the the different leaders in
civilization but each each affinity kind
of gives you a brand new game to play so
that's really one of the ways that we we
use that these ideas that the will and
Dave developed to to add another
dimension of replay
ability to the starships how many
harmony fans do we have in the house
that's that's not a lot of super
supremacy what about purity alright
sounds like y'all a bunch of robot
loving some some cooks mentors of space
so you know one of the one of the ways
you see affinity is sort of in your
leader and looking up here on the the
slide show those are the leaders we've
seen I recognize kavitha those are the
same characters we had in beyond Earth's
so did they build those characters their
personalities play part in starships
they definitely do you will run into
these characters that you're familiar
with from beyond earth again in
starships in fact one of the ways that
we can connect the games is to to take
the situation from your beyond Earth
game and bring the same leaders back
into your starships game with the same
rivalries if they're at war and beyond
Earth W at war in starships if they're
at peace in beyond Earth w peace and
starships just one way to play their
many different ways to play but if you
if you think that kind of connection
would be fun you can do that people have
asked us well how do these people live
for five hundred or thousand years you
know to connect down to earth to
starships well it's science fiction you
know so we don't worry about that
they're cool we want the back and way to
own it yeah I think we can do a whole
packs panel on the the abstraction of
the leader civilization game it's like a
the curtain in a show in a stage play
you understand that that's not a part of
the play just as you understand George
Washington doesn't live for a thousand
years in a civilization game so but
science fiction
alright well let's talk a little bit
about the leaders let's talk a little
bit about I guess we're going to see
more sort of the ebb and flow of
starships when we do the demo a little
bit later on in the panel but you know
in terms of the sort of thematic scope
of starships it's quite a bit smaller
than civilization naturally I mean
almost all games are quite a bit smaller
than civilization in terms of scope but
combat and sort of the tactical
challenge there on a on a hex based
battlefield is still sort of is it the
heart of the game is at the brain what
sort of rolled place in starships is
that part of the action play that's
really the one of the initial design
questions is kind of where is your focus
and since this game is called starships
the focus is on your fleet of starships
and everything else in the game is
either directly related to that or
related to something else that's
directly related to that so your role
again when when I look at the topic it's
like what are the cool parts of this
there's tons of stuff out there but what
are the coolest parts of this topic of
this world and the idea of commanding a
fleet of starships of customizing them
of building them of upgrading them of
using them on a variety of missions
throughout the galaxy to do good stuff
for all the good people that are out
there you know I think that that's kind
of the core of the game hmm there's a
galactic map where let you explore and
you and the kind of gives you this
overview of what's going on and gives
you these various missions and and the
opportunity to expand your Federation
and we'll look at will see that a little
bit more later on but the focus is on
you and your fleet of starships and all
the fun things that you can do with them
and that that leads to the combat to
building to to exploring again I guess
the Star Trek was in my mind when I when
I came up with a lot of this stuff but
it's it's it's about that fleet of
starships and the story that you create
with them from starting from your loan
planet where you've just finished your
cool beyond Earth game up until the end
of the game where hopefully you've
conquered the galaxy so you're almost
more of a Fleet Admiral
starships sort of captain then sort of
the monolithic leader who's setting
Paula social policy and driving the
culture and stuff like that and I think
it's because when when we look at that
situation it's like what's the most fun
what's the most fun person who's having
the most fun in that world you know and
i think it's the guy commanding the
starships the guy or gal not the
monolithic leader of a gigantic civil
activist is a shin so you know it's
really the question that we ask when we
look at something is who is having the
most fun of this world and let's be that
person and that's kind of the way we
structured starships well that seems
like you're speaking so the challenge
any game designer has you know what is
what's the most fun thing to do in this
world what is going to be the sort of
the focus of the this this thing that I
want to create will and Dave here beyond
Earth obviously the focus is much
greater but you still had to make a lot
of choices you know even with the sort
of the weight of the history of the
series you know the civilization
carrying that civilization banner you
still had to make a lot of choices about
what you think is fun what you think is
going to be rewarding for the player in
beyond Earth so how did that how do you
sort of parse that out well i think is
as a game designer you're always looking
for and this is this is a term sit uses
a lot this sort of center of gravity of
your game like where does that core
exist and what's kind of neat about
starships when you look at it and
compared in comparison to civilization
is a starship structure is much more
like XCOM actually so the this you have
this very grand scope talking about
scope here grand scale view of the
universe and then these tactical
engagements and the the fleet that
carries over between them and that's
kind of the ExCom structure morse more
than it is the substructure but you
still have civ elements in there you've
got planets that you can improve and
resources that you're managing and
there's there's a lot of things there as
well in terms of our game we we had we
had to make a lot of choices as to where
the center of gravity of that product
was was it that was it the narrative was
that the tactical gameplay was at the
the construction of your cities and I
don't know maybe that's a false choice
maybe it's all of those things you know
that's it right it's a really big
oked game but with starships it's very
cool because they're these these focused
awesome focus tactical engagements
coupled with this grand strategy aspect
yeah I always felt likes it was that was
it was the game that said that those are
all false choices that you could have
everything in the same game and you know
it's interesting there's a lot of
elements in starships that we we
originally thought about putting in
beyond Earth and didn't put in because
we wanted to maintain its focus like one
of the earliest questions that people
had for be on earth is it's going to be
multiple planets that you could to play
on and we rejected that immediately not
because it's you know not necessarily a
good game idea but because for us it was
really important that the story of
beyond or 'this is sort of intimate it's
kind of it's it's really the story of
one world and and just one part of it
really you're part of it your
civilization on it kind of figuring out
what this world is and how you're going
to be part of it and how you're going to
get along with or not as the case may be
the other people that live on it and so
that's why you know the beginning of
beyond earth feels very scary it's very
survival istic with aliens everywhere in
danger and you're just this little some
guys in a spacesuit trying to just
trying not to get squished into dust
long enough to to develop something that
you can call your own that's really you
know you taking ownership of the world
and finding your way on it and starships
kind of takes it i always felt when I
play it feel like it goes from the other
perspective if it has a very Star Trek
vibe where you are a collection of kind
of bold adventurers kind of sallying out
into a world it's already full of life
and activity and excitement and
adventure and you're not its danger in a
different way you the story is is kind
of like how you how you meet those
challenges and what you might find over
the next over the next hill top or
around the next planet and less about
like how that world comes to you and
interacts with your civilization so now
the starships has made it I feel like
actually it lends a lot of insight into
why we made beyond Earth and Weiss if
the games are made the way
why they have the focus where they do
because we get to see it from the other
side you know what would happen if
you're at the big big camera instead of
the little camera I know out in space
rather than standing on the surface it's
uh it's a really fun way to view the the
beyonders idea from the starships
perspective yeah I know one of the
challenges we have with a civil series
is the scope and we actually have a rule
that for every new system that goes in
we have to take an old system out
because the topic is so rich that we
could clearly overwhelmed the player
with all sorts of minutiae and basically
the fun goes away and it becomes
micromanagement games so we're
constantly really keeping an eye on that
idea that the players in charge the
players a star the player is driving the
story and and and the game it supports
them in doing that it's not that the
player has to kind of try and figure out
all the time what's going on and and so
that's a challenge i know that will and
Dave face and we all face as designers
ever since we got past 64k of memory we
could write games that were way too
complicated and we have to rein
ourselves in luckily we're all gamers in
a sensitive I think too that that that
issue and that's sort of reining
yourselves in can can be a creative
challenge in and of itself I mean
especially when you're working on
something like starships or like ace
patrol it is sort of narrowing the focus
down and but then because your scope is
more limited you have to do a little bit
more mining and a little bit more
meticulous system building is you know
just sort of picturing you gave me this
image of Firaxis just here's the cutting
room floor of all these things we
couldn't put into sieve but what if we
drill down on this what if we made this
a game I mean what's your what's your
kind of process internally or I guess
even for yourselves personally about
thinking oh well what if I did make make
this smaller version of the game how
would that work what would what would be
enriching from that well I think we are
constantly playing the games in that
that core tenets of development at
Firaxis and the other thing that we we
try to do is get something a prototype
playing very early so
we don't storyboard we don't have
everything figured out at the very
beginning it's really a process of
discovery going through the game design
iterating every day playing figuring out
if this new feature is working or not
working and so I think that's really
what is the discipline for us in terms
of adding too many features is we're
suddenly find ourselves having less fun
or not having enough features we
suddenly find ourselves not having much
fun and so there are i'd say probably a
third to a half of the code that you
write for a game gets thrown out the
third to a half of the features that you
try to put in don't end up in the final
game and that's really one of the
strengths I think that we have as a
company is that our designers generally
generally are programmers as well so
that so I mean I find that I'm much more
willing to try and design idea if I can
just code it myself and see if it works
as opposed to having to explain it to
somebody else and then go back to them
two days later say oh gosh you know that
thing that you worked on so hard it's
not that great we got to take it out
again so you know I think that the core
of our design process is iterating and
playing and that's really how we decide
kind of on these new scope type of
issues and what's really supporting the
game was really helping it and what's
really getting the way getting in the
way of the fun yeah in many cases we
selsun we self-regulate like we can't
you can't say all of these features are
going to go in the game because it's
usually us that are putting them in so
to save work so very I'm very lazy rich
again we can't type that much you know
all right well I you guys talk about
personalization and sort of Dave talking
about how beyond Earth being that
intimate story and you know
personalization when you're making
choices about where to settle and where
to send your explorers and what how to
chart your course through the tech tree
you know these are all sort of familiar
see if kind of personal and
personalizations but a lot of those
things don't carry through to starships
in the same way you know we've seen
obviously you can put some cool racing
stripes on your ships
depending on what your affinity is you
know they sort of look a different way
that affinities are part of the
personalization but i guess as you as
you guide your fleet through a game of
starships how does it become your own
there are a couple of I guess they've
almost become second nature to us at
fracks in a couple of ways that we we
try to make sure that we place the
player in that starring role and give
them this you know a wide range of
options in terms of play you know one of
the things is the idea replayability
that there are many different ways of
playing which means that as you look
back on your gameplay experience the
story that you've created you can be
pretty assured that that's unique that
no one else has gone through that exact
that same process that same series of
missions that same series of decisions
and gone through that path so you every
time you play you are creating a brand
new experience in whether it's SIV or
beyond Earth or XCOM or starships it's
almost kind of second nature I think to
us as designers now that we know that we
want every player to have a unique
experience as they as they play the game
and and that comes down to a rigid set
of starting options a lot of you know
random apps are pretty much fundamental
to our game design philosophy a variety
of difficulty levels to let you kind of
really explore at your own pace the the
the you know comes back to interesting
decisions giving the player lots of
interesting decisions in which means to
us that they could have gone either way
so one player is going to take one path
and other players going to take another
path and hopefully at the end of the day
when you've played through our games you
know through one iteration of the game
you know that's been a unique play
experience that only you have
experienced and you want to play it
again to go through another path and
that path choosing was something the US
will and Dave sort of developed a new
system and beyond Earth the the quest
idea that sort of choices that help sort
of guide the player in terms of their
thinking about the world that they were
chartings because you know you guys have
to do a ton of thinking about the future
of humanity and what you know what
kind of world you want to create all
these possibilities within does that
make you just sort of creating that kind
of those choices do you feel that you
bring optimism to it about the future of
humanity that doesn't make you a little
depress when you have to put in so many
weapons no no it's some that's how many
people like weapons yeah sorry yeah yeah
no that I mean actually like developing
the quests threads was probably one of
the most rewarding parts of designing
the game because that's really where all
of this kind of the overflowing
enthusiasm that we have for the topic
not all of which will translate into a
specific mechanic that's where it finds
its way into the game that's were like
that's really where you see our love of
it the subject matter is we're like the
quest narratives and the ideas we say
like hey have you ever thought about if
if if we were cybernetically augmented
would access to electricity be a human
right you know like stuff like that you
know things that are that are kind of
off-the-wall offshoots of contemplating
futurism that the quest system was was i
would say in a very real sense add to
the game in order to enable like we put
it in there because we wanted to show
this side of the world to the player we
wanted to invite them to think about it
and decide what it meant to them and
there's just so much potential and so
much enthusiasm in the in the quest
system I mean the idea of a quest is not
we certainly didn't invent that but I
really think that beyond earth wouldn't
have been a rich experience without it
you think about how you know sci fi is
often considered to be a very cold genre
because it's so alien because it's
representing things that no human has
ever experienced in asking people today
to relate to them you got to offer them
something that they can recognize and
and the some of the ideas we put in the
quest is amor are our way of doing that
our fans have said have resonated with
it very well and I think we've received
a lot of feedback and Kateri people
really reacting with a lot of joy and
excitement for the sort of ideas were in
the in the quest system I think the
concept of affinities is very similar to
that you know this where where we end up
what's the posthuman trajectory for
for us and when we venture out into
space how do we take that and formalize
it as a mechanic that the affinity
system is very successful and that
carried through into starships as well
so if you but you you get to select your
affinity at the beginning of the game in
starships whereas and beyond Earth you
sort of arrived at that affinity through
all of your choices so it's an
interesting it's a different take on on
the idea of affinity in starships but
that concept is all what has always been
very cool to us all right well we're
just about ready to hop into the demo
here but before we get in there just
have one more question for you guys
thinking of all this space faring sort
of puts me in mind of games like elite
dangerous and Eve Valkyrie and the
oculus rift and Microsoft's recently
announced hullo goggle majig when do you
guys think about that kind of that kind
of future you know that kind of tech did
does that inspire you these it tickle
yer tickle your design center Microsoft
is listening please send for access one
of those holla ma jigs and that guy to
that would be really nice we would
appreciate it we're always looking for
new ways to engage our fans we're
looking for new platforms we're looking
for new ways to to reach to reach
players and you know starships is for pc
and iOS or ipad so that's that's cool
it's you know the same game across both
of those platforms that's something that
we're we want to do that right we want
to make sure that it's not just a port
but we want to design the games
fundamentally to be playable on whatever
we decide that they're they're best
suited for and not compromise so I think
you know if there was ever a cockpit
sort of game that came along that
firaxis wanted to make sure citiz some
some oculus rifts or thingamajigs
Microsoft thingamajigs but yeah of
course it's it's a changing landscape it
always we're always seeing new stuff and
are always getting excited about it I
think for us it always comes down to
gameplay it's gameplay first and
are not big on sort of shoehorning our
games into into new devices until we
sort of figure out a really good use for
them and and so we may move a little bit
more slowly in that area but we're
always very interested well speaking of
new stuff are you guys excited to see
Sid Meier's starships in action our
ancestors cross the great void untold
millennia ago pilgrims from a dying
world long since lost from tumultuous
beginnings their struggle courage and
fortitude gave birth to our civilization
for many centuries our people prospered
peace ruled our planet and our
understanding of the world around us
grew our scientists have long speculated
that ours was not the only tribe to make
this journey and establish a new home on
another world but they're searching has
been met again and again with silence
until now
the transmission was weak and incomplete
but in a language not unlike our own our
anticipation Peru what culture and
knowledge had our brothers developed
during the long centuries of our
separation a starship was prepared
ambassadors recruited but gradually the
meaning of the message became clear it
was a desperate call for help
galvanized by the revelation that we are
not alone our fleet has been equipped
we are ready to answer the call of our
brethren
what shall we find
as we set our course beyond the stars
so that was really what inspired me that
that the idea that we played this beyond
Earth game we won we had this beautiful
planet and we've been here for five
hundred years life it's good we're
improving everything is wonderful and
we're wondering what happened to the
other members of humanity that were part
of the seating and we're searching for
them and we get we get a faint message
and we say oh we're looking forward to
meeting these people they probably have
a wonderful planet where there are doing
happy things too and we're just going to
get together and have a group hug you
know and but of course life isn't that
simple so as we understand what's going
on we realize that there's trouble in
the galaxy we are developing these
starships and it's our role to go out
and fix what's wrong with this with this
galaxy and that's where the story begins
I'll take you through some of our game
play here start a new game first thing
we're going to look at is the affinities
again which are familiar from beyond
Earth but they each have some some kind
of interesting benefits that will will
take you down an interesting path as you
play the game and our leaders again kind
of change their appearance to reflect
their connection to the different
affinities the supremacy has kind of a
cool benefit that they get a wonder a
free wonder at the very beginning of the
game on random wonder and that can kind
of give you an idea what path you might
want to start down so choosing your
affinity is is the first step and then
you're going to choose which of these
leaders is going to represent your
Federation each of them again has an
advantage technology kavitha as
humanitarian Boulevard gets an extra
starship which is very cool house love
more metal I like technology so we go
this direction again a lot of options in
terms of the size of the map how long do
you want to play how many opponents do
you want
again there's many many different ways
to to to set up your your game what
we're going to go kind of right into it
here so this is the first view we get of
our galaxy this is our home planet here
pegasi 77 it is generating some
resources for us there's energy metal
technology and food these are resources
that we're going to use to build up our
our planet and our Empire Oh over here
is this planet that we've got indistinct
signal from and what is telling us is
that there's a mission they're available
called duel at dawn the reward for
completing that mission is going to be
to get one free technology there's one
city on this planet fairly small planet
and they have a special ability which is
to build fighters at a reduced cost and
if we can make this a planet part of our
Federation will get that special ability
so again the planets have a variety of
abilities which which makes every game
play again in a slightly different
matter our basic commands here are we
can upgrade and build our starships we
can research new technology go to the
market and buy and sell different
resources diplomacy which is something
that comes into effect later in the game
the first thing we want to do is kind of
look at our starships and customize them
what's our strategy what's our plan how
are we going to go out in the galaxy and
and succeed and knowing that we have the
cloaking wonder the cloaking wonder
allows us to use our stealth systems at
no cost normally we'd have to make a
decision between cloaking ourselves and
using our weapons for example but with
the cloaking wonder we can do both so
that's going to drive some of the
decision making in terms of customizing
our starships at the beginning of the
game we have two starships decked out in
total supremacy garb and every starship
is built of a number of modules which
can all be upgraded we have our engines
which give us more speed and energy
that's how we would upgrade our engines
we have shields which
absorb damage armor which is part of our
protection lasers which are long-range
weapons cannon which are shorter range
weapons but more powerful torpedoes
which we can launch they move slowly but
they they can pass through asteroid
fields we have sensors the case the
enemy is trying to cloak themselves we
can seek them out with sensors our own
stealth technology we can add that to
our ship we can also attach fighters to
our ship at launch them as part of the
battle so there's a lot of different
options a lot of different ways you can
customize and configure your starships
you might want a fast reconnaissance
ship with a lot of speed and a lot of
sensors a tank with cannons and a lot of
armor all sorts of options an aircraft
carrier with a bunch of fighters on it a
submarine carrying a lot of torpedoes
over there there's all sorts of
different ways you can customize and
configure your Starfleet in this case
since I have the the cloaking wonder I'm
going to make sure and put a couple of
stealth modules on life starships and
the currency that i use to upgrade my
starship is called energy the more
energy i have the more cool stuff i can
i can add to my to my starships hmm so
I've added to stealth modules to each of
my starship so I'm starting to run out
of energy here I can sell these fighters
I don't think I'm going to need those
fighters my strategy is going to be to
kind of hang back hide and use my
long-range lasers to take out any any
bad guys out there okay I've run out of
energy time to move on hmm so there's
trouble here we just got a transmission
we're going to go to linksys 88 see what
the problem is Oh 68 I'm sorry
so as we approached Weaver's we received
this transmission there's some rotters
out there Marauders are not friendly
people they are making trouble all over
the galaxy and their commander has
challenged us to a duel his two best
ships against our two best ships we go
to the bridge of our flagship here here
we have our crew again fully fully
supremacist and they are here to help us
get ready for this mission so we want to
know what is unique about this planet
that we're circling so what's what's
interesting here is there's a ring of
debris surrounding this planet it's
going to mean there's a kind of a no-go
area around the planet they've already
scoped out the Marauders and they can
tell us who we're going to be up against
there the Marauders thank you there are
the Marauders have two Corvettes again
you can see which modules are on the
ships and kind of plan your strategy in
terms of taking them on one interesting
thing is that we actually have the
option before the battle to go back and
wreak us to buy our starships if we
think that this battle these starships
are not set up appropriately for the
battle that's about to come the mission
we're about to embark on we can
reconfigure them so these starships are
very a dynamic part of the part of the
game hmm I guess we can ask for some
advice upgrading the weapons of our
starship should be a priority for I
think we've already done that thank you
so it's time to go into this mission
here's a reminder what are what our goal
is and what's kind of unique about this
world
now these are the Marauder ships that
were watching right now they've launched
some fighters you can see the ring of
debris around the planet we love we love
maps don't we we don't we love Maps
couldn't have a game without at least
one map maps are just wonderful in terms
of presenting you these interesting
space and distance kind of issues making
positioning important making facing
important giving you a lot of
interesting things to think about so how
do you how do you put maps in space it
was a question well there's all these
asteroids imagine there's a lot of
asteroids around and they really kind of
create the play area for each for each
battle in for each mission and allow
each mission to be very very different
asteroids are areas that ships cannot
pass through and they also provide cover
from the fire of enemy starships so kind
of looking at the lay of the land
looking at your map and using it to your
advantage is a very important skill in
terms of playing starships what happens
is we can see that our cloaking hasn't
been automatically turned on as we as we
move as promised by the Wonder that we
had at the beginning of the game and as
we look at our opportunities to fire
enemy ships we can see how much damage
we can we would do from different
positions on the map and what's
happening is that any asteroid fields or
debris that our chat has to pass through
is going to attenuate the shot it's
going to be less effective and vice
versa if we're if we're behind asteroids
that'll protect us from the fire from
enemy ships so it's important to kind of
look at the the situation in terms of
asteroids and the lay of the land and
figure out what to do another
interesting aspect of the battlefield
are these green and red circles they are
narrow passages between the asteroids
and over the course of the battle
they'll open and close one turn this
passage might be open the next term it
might be closed so the battlefield is
actually dynamic it's changing as you
uh as you go through the battle so you
may be waiting for one of these passages
to open or you again they become part of
your your play strategy as you as you go
through the battle I want to get too
close because if an enemy ship gets
inside that radius of my cloaking device
they're going to be able to see me but
right now they can't see me huh I've
gotten in a position here where I don't
have a whole lot of asteroids between my
ship and the enemy ship which is going
to allow me to have a pretty clean shot
at the enemy ship and do 74 hit points
worth of damage and if I look at the
stats at the bottom of the screen i see
they only have 55 hit points so I'm
feeling pretty good about this
particular shot wow that was fun
now the other ship is a little farther
away it can't quite go 82 well nice
enjoy well you know some days you're
lucky so there the fighters he launched
hmm again they still can't see me
because of the cloaking advantage we
have and this this narrow passage is
opened up here allow me to get quite
close to the enemy wow wow all right
take that you Marauders so now that
we've done this wonderful mission helped
out the people this planet they're going
to start to become friendly towards us
fat now they're going to open up a trade
route with us and as we go back to the
Galactic map oh I'm sorry the reward for
this mission almost forgotten was one
free technology so an interesting thing
about the technologies is they're all
related to the capabilities of your
starships it's not like your coop sorry
it's not like you're exploring a bunch
of different avenues it's it's getting
cooler stuff for your starships so the
technologies in this game allow your
secure systems to be more effective and
since we're kind of focusing on the idea
of stealth we're going to upgrade our
quantum suppression technology here
which would normally cost us 400 science
points we get it for free here so we now
have more effective stealth systems what
we discover as as we've completed this
mission there's a bigger galaxy out
there now that we've gone to linces 68
we see their other planets out there we
notice there are other missions
available the green missions are the
easier missions as the game progresses
there going to be some more difficult
missions and again each of the planets
has an advantage a system that they can
upgrade more effectively over here
they're going to do science research
more quickly different rewards that are
available for for carrying out the
different missions and our next decision
is going to be which planet do we go to
next who are going to help out next
what's what's the reward that we're
really interested in getting next we can
see here that we're starting to get some
of the resources from this planet as a
result of the trade route that was
established because we did the mission
and we also have to influence public
points here basically once we get for
influence points by accomplishing
missions this this planet becomes part
of our Federation hmm so that it's just
a
early taste of what goes on in the game
just one other aspect i want to point
out to you is it's down here is our crew
the green heads are happy and wide awake
crew members but as we travel and as we
accomplish missions they start to get
tired we right now have three tired
tired crew members you can see their
little brain waves aren't is wavy as the
green room ever brain waves and it's the
challenge here is that we can we can
pursue this voyage as long as we as long
as we dare but as we get deeper and
deeper into it our crew is going to
become more and more fatigued and less
effective so we're kind of going to see
how far we want to push our luck when we
feel that they deserve a rest we're
going to go on shore leave over here and
they all kind of come back to full
efficiency but that gives the other
players in the game a chance to take
their turns and now we're seeing the
other civilizations that are out there
also doing the same types of things that
we're doing and gradually as the game
progresses they become more more of our
rivals so we've completed our shore
leave and a crew is happy again and
we're ready to take to embark on another
another voyage when we going to do
really quickly here is load up a game
from from a save game for much later in
the game just to give you a feel for how
things evolve so this is kind of in the
middle of the game our Empire I mean our
Federation for the good of humanity I'm
sorry sorry about our Federation has
expanded and brought joy peace and
happiness too many of these planets we
have been in contact some of the other
leaders out there we can talk to them
negotiate with them get information
about what they're what they're up to
here's Elodie these are the planets that
she controls this is what her fleet
looks like so the game gradually grows
and grows into a bigger and bigger or
more epic saga of what's going on in in
the galaxy and our fleet is up here next
to her territory apparently she doesn't
care for us all that much that will be
her problem shortly so we're going to go
into a battle just to give you a feel
that the battles kind of grow and grow
in in dimension as as the game
progresses so our fleet has grown here's
LEDs fleet she actually has some mega
bots that are defending her home planet
hmm I'm sure we'd win this battle of
course you know so we don't have to go
through it but that kind of gives you I
think hopefully a little bit of a taste
of what the gate what the gameplay is
and what the gameplay involves we will
be doing some live streams and bringing
out some more information as time goes
on with some more details about the game
but just kind of a quick overview of
some of the gameplay elements that we
have in starships
you